here's a neat trick which has almost
three quarters of a million hits so far
make a paper airplane Jake two fans put
them on opposite sides position your
airplane between them
enjoy your hovering paper airplane but
is it real as to get a plane to fly you
need a strong flow of air moving across
the wings that creates a difference in
the pressure above and below the wings
and that's what gives a plane lift so
the first fan looks like it's doing all
the right things they've introduced a
second fan in a direction exactly
opposite to the first one because it
would immediately push the air in the
opposite direction so you would kind of
stabilize the plane in the middle it's
just something not quite right about it
the first thing is that if you put a
second fan there it's gonna cancel the
flow from the first fan and so
essentially you won't have air flowing
over the wings and you won't have any
lift but it's even worse than that
because by having a second flow you're
creating a very turbulent environment
right where the airplane is and
turbulence is the exact opposite of this
smooth flow and you will have no lift
whatsoever so how do they do it
fishing way
okay don't believe everything you see on
the Internet